there's a fascinating docu-series soon
to be released about the trump family i
genuinely am looking forward to this
there's not a lot of stuff like this
that i look forward to the political
playbook was able to exclusively obtain
footage sort of like a two-minute
trailer
from a docu-series about the trump
family and the trump riots uh this was
produced by alex holder it's called
unprecedented it's a
alex holder is a british filmmaker it's
going to be on discovery plus let's
check out the trailer this is really
really interesting stuff
[Music]
okay do you see this line
[Music]
tired i did uh evangelicals for trump
and i did indian americans for trump
than i did asian pacific yeah americans
for trump
[Music]
my father the people's president we will
make liberals cry again
i don't think you won't have the water
in the picture
you can take
[Music]
so it a family we've done 55 events in
48 hours
[Music]
the campaign basically was a family
operation washing my hands after giving
a bunch of fist bumps you know is that
okay
yeah i must we'll take the table maybe i
should just like makatsu have the like
dog on my lap
can i borrow your dog can i wear a [ __ ]
up
stroking that's why i broke put the
table back and put the water on the
table without the thing on top of it
[Music]
this is a business oh this feels good or
you have to be in it for the right
reasons
this is a fraud
on the american public for the sake of
this country we're gonna get these guys
let's kick some ass
let's win
let's walk down pennsylvania avenue they
threw the damn match
you gotta get the roaches out all of
them when you manipulate people that has
consequences
donald trump was able to use his
children as the embodiment of trump the
brand he's an unconventional person he
believes that everything that he's doing
is right how does that look trump has
always looked at his project as a
dynastic one
they have a base they have their own
base people have no idea how hard this
family worked it's part of my base
[Music]
this is my house
right let's go
do you miss me yet do you miss
i think this is going to be absolutely
fascinating and to be perfectly honest
the trailer looks like a mockumentary i
mean when you see some of these shots of
the behind the scenes of trump
figuring out how he wants to sit and
whether he wants water next to him or
whatever it seems like a mockumentary
but these people were in power for four
years
they might be in power again and i think
it's going to be an absolutely
fascinating docu-series i'm looking
forward to it we'll review it when it
finally comes out one of our sponsors
today is bluechew a unique online
service delivering the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost and they're giving my audience an
entire month supply for free so if you
think you could benefit from an extra
boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping